all right are you a magician
I can't believe that was the vote I mean
the profession that got the most votes
of people on the street I should have
worn I should have won a suit we're
gonna play some chess we're gonna play
best of three we're having a blast today
we've talked to a lot of people on the
street levy on the street good luck sir
I'll do the Chris you fizbump there we
go all right
[Music]
let's give you the phone man give me the
bishop here give me the pawn I'm into it
I don't know what to play I'm actually
thinking yeah split shots though
I guess I gotta play this stupid okay
okay
I don't know why I'm saying okay but I
am
hey fine yeah let's do it just like that
and then do it
um
all right
I'm gonna get out I'm actually stressed
with a great movie by the way Jordan
peel great movie get out
why would you do that why would you do
that I don't I'm not into that
okay we're gonna back back this thing up
d8 or E8 what do you think
maybe all the way to d8 I guess it's
gonna say I like E8 but
you know you're probably right you are
Levy Rosman after all I am not attacking
each other
yeah we're gonna do this oh my goodness
we're gonna do this I'm stressing this
is so much fun actually I don't like
these pieces and I don't like I don't
like anything about this chessboard I
don't like these pieces and I don't like
you all right oh big yo get over it
yo forget about it just pulling out all
of the traditionally stereotypical New
York lines that's what I have to do but
I'm missing some
uh
you know that there's no attack here
right like this is one of those games
where
you know probably I've already missed a
few wins
um but I
no but I think what I already had that
tactic before I think you missed it
because you forgot this wasn't a bishop
this was a bishop oh no no I I know it
was a bishop hold on hold on
what about this oh here we go some spicy
happening OMG sir snaps
that's it that's gonna do it right come
on are you what are you doing here
you're creatively saving this game in a
shocking shocking way
like no joke yeah the ghost of Eric
Rosen goes wrong Eric Rosen
I've been swindled so many times by Eric
Rosen
we can all agree that Eric Rosen has
swindled too many what am I it's
magnetic
I'm getting down on time
I'm gonna do it
I feel how did we trade all the pieces I
don't know how anybody got out of that
alive but I feel like I should be
winning
oh my God wait what how did that happen
I thought I was just catching you
oops I think if you played D6 after A4
what what did I think huh okay
you can just leave it I get it I get
what you're trying to do
how did oh I didn't expect that
the the
Danny no
why I don't know sir oh my God it's an
active
that was hilarious oh what am I doing am
I gonna stalemate you no I'm gonna make
you push that pawn oh that was good
is real
and it exists you almost got the
stalemate bro almost got this feeling
all right best we're going we go again
all right now we go again now I remember
how the pieces moved you what are we
doing now we went back to that one okay
I'm gonna go E4 because I wouldn't want
to disappoint oh my God hi guys it's me
John team's candy hi guys
it's me John
hi guys it's me John
you're like a robot with like one voice
line it's like it's broke it broke my
robot voice broke
oh my God that's aggressive
you don't have to be that worried about
my attack
you know I was I was very worried
the question now is what I have here
[Music]
good dude just kidding I actually moved
the piece I didn't adjust it that was
super funny I can't have my Bishop yeah
I saw that let's go move
now I gotta defend against the threats
now writing all sorts of how aggressive
do I get here
I think I should bring my king into the
game
wow
they want to move
pretty much every move I ask what would
Magnus play
and do the just God speak to you
sometimes
do I want your Bishop I'm gonna I'm
gonna pretend I do I'm not actually sure
if I do but I'm gonna pretend I do
[Music]
it's very impressive I watch a lot of
Gotham chess videos that would make you
a worse chess player he's a very good
teacher I wonder how many people here
watch Gotham chess videos I do
[Music]
I didn't know why I was in such a good
mood and now I've realized the drum beat
has been going on in the background
these magnetic pieces are going to be
the death of me this is a good move oh
my goodness all right I gotta go here
no
two pawns are better than one where was
all of this
in your matches I'm so confused maybe
you're bringing the best out of me I
yeah it seems that way you're bringing
the best chess out of me yeah
all right let's get let's get it it's
crazy let's get a deep on
let's let's do it uh
yeah we'll go there
we're gonna take it there's leaves
falling on my head but now there's only
one clock now there's only one clock I
opened the retreating Square for the
king I attacked your Rook
I said what I was doing out loud
thank you
I don't know what I'm doing anymore
though
it's clean
of what are you doing now you adorable
little kitten
all right you're giving me games here
stop it you're growing for Content this
is this is the chief chess officer right
here well best of three is like pretty
good but I feel like I warm up after two
games okay so best of five yeah let's
get best of five all right here we go
here we go again
okay the English
[Music]
if all those phenomenons and Boards
looking different over the board they
really do yeah
yeah I like can't I can't see anything
these pieces are not great but
I don't know I just
I think you got some fans over there let
me do I and not just of the shirt either
this time Danny I have my best position
in three games don't distract me I know
you do
um oh my God it's going on here
[Music]
oh man okay now my game is falling apart
yeah Tony showed up and now you got
scared
[Music]
I wish I could do Gary because far off
like like Don you can yeah you know you
know well you know and you know
all right that's just what it's just
signature
just letting me take the pawn I have a
strategy I'm gonna go for my other Pond
indeed but I still have two pawns I know
but
I thought maybe this was a slightly
better holding chances and maybe not
um all I need is a draw
to clinch the mess not necessarily to
clinch the match but just to feel good
about myself
[Music]
this is so annoying I feel like one of
those super GMS that's going to
tragically throw magically draw a
Perpetual yep I hope so
um not really though not really you are
I am
[Music]
doing what I can here to keep it spicy
yeah
it's not looking real great for me now
is it oh no not really
there you go there you go there you go
boy
ah wait wait hold on hold on hold on
wait what okay all right all right we
gotta keep going Tony until we get to
Best of five because he just woke up
we're telling you have a clock
do you have a real one yes can we have
it he also has real pieces do you have
real pieces because he's prepared Tony
oh let's switch man
we can't take it anymore
no we changed it up every game all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna
okay okay what E6 V6 Sports only if I
only only if I win only a few minutes
yeah here we go yeah I play this every
single time so aggressive dang it all in
I'm all in on the on the attack baby
[Music]
yeah I do love space I do love space
um what's your favorite planet
oh my favorite planet my favorite planet
is um we're gonna do it
um
pattern or Jupiter okay okay
what's up Jupiter is Big satin cold
what you doing okay Venus
we watching a movie
um and basically it was it wasn't that
long it was like a storm it was like 12
minutes right but it was in Venus that's
where it's taking place right and the
kids only see the sun seven times a year
for one hour so the kids are all nine
when they were two years old they didn't
remember the sun coming out so there's
one girl who remembered it
um
and they were bullying here because if
she didn't because they didn't realize
that they thought she was lying and then
they locked her in a closet
wow if I lose this game it's because of
this movie I don't know what's going on
anymore and then they the sun came out
truly after and then uh and then they
realized it was like the movies had all
summer in one day
um but it was like the sun came out for
one hour yeah it came out for one hour
and then they unlocked that from the
closet and they all said sorry
that was a lot man and then it takes
seven more years for the sun to come out
again
your son is slacking why is the Sun not
coming out more because it's Venus
a lot of time I spent so much time
thinking about that movie that good it's
so interesting I already got it
I feel like this is
this is not where I was wait a minute to
go just a lot you just helped it
[Music]
is I feel like nobody's planning this
game has been pretty nobody nobody knows
what they're doing in this guys I think
they didn't do no planning better than
30 seconds
[Music]
I have so many pawns absolutely wild run
oh oh my God what is going on here this
is insane who's winning I don't know
actually
I think Levy's learning
oh no no how did that happen oh my God
that was wild okay all right game five
it's more excited completing an epic
comeback this is for all the marbles
right here just for the win man this is
crazy thank you
against the guy in the back thanks to
you oh yeah call me chess right yeah
there you go
I'm so nervous I'm playing Gotham chess
so I'm nervous I feel like all right
here we go three two one yeah game five
good luck for the internet going online
it's going online you can't take it back
now tell you what cowboy accent
you don't you don't know what I'm doing
during the 1990s like just I liked it
yeah man this is what it's all about is
it what McDonald's I would always do
thank you for the fun on B5 on A6 and
play it again
I like the commentary I like yeah
this would look as far as it in this
book I just finished reading it yeah I
don't know he has a million books but
like you put his Bishop on H6 H5 H4
close your eyes open them check me close
your eyes open each other I wish my
games went like that
I think it's all the way around
huh this is what happens when you play a
benoni
yeah you're
goodbye this is bad things happening
this is so interesting is bad for black
yeah I should go watch a golf and chess
video about this structure yeah
okay okay I gotta
five worst openings
I think that was a video something this
is probably one of them the one thing
about the benoni though is if you don't
bust it
it creeps up on you yeah yeah is like if
you don't take advantage of it you lose
if you take advantage you win yeah kind
of agreed to him unless you're Magnus
then you always win yeah don't always
though check
um
I'm debating where do I want this King
there's so many options here
the first tournament I ever played I
lost all three games
yeah I'm sorry to hear that I actually
lost all of my games in Minecraft
tournament too fun fact
I won all my games really yeah I lost
all the games in my second tournament ah
I can Castle right that's not something
illegal
it's the story of my life you know I
jump out to a lead to make sure that we
have content and then I fall apart
and the best chess always wins
oh my God I know I know can you really
nice I don't think so I mean wow
foreign
[Music]
by this I don't need this guy
um
all right Donnie one more one more
everyone's enjoying your commentary
here we go game on I gotta play my
favorite open oh my God all Pawns in no
hope you have to make this account you
have to change it
thank you
what
yeah what is this yeah
I don't look at the tea away is this a
line
I think it is now yeah Daddy's playing
it so I think he just made it a line I
don't know yeah it's a move for sure it
doesn't look stupid
[Music]
I was at the world open and um I was I
won the game on time because I like my
opponent accidentally hit the clock
twice
on the 40 move rule so we get the 40
moves and he didn't get to um well he
didn't get the 40 moves and he got the
extra time and I won the game if I was
losing I was like you lost and then Etc
but I was completely amazing I just said
let's keep playing it very much so I won
the game twice
a little bit confused about the facts of
the case
I'm sure it was uh I'm sure you I'm sure
it was a good good move by
oh I am slightly confused about what to
do here this is what the Terracon does
to you I've got an idea yeah I would buy
it I'm gonna do it be like oh yeah right
yeah
I'm going it doesn't lose your Rook I
think I'm just going to move my knight
to be honest
all right that was it that's all you got
to do yeah yeah maybe this might be
filler in the center the queen looks a
little dicey okay it's not in the game
right now it's supposed to be like
people like this is just what are we
doing here what are we doing here
what is going on
exclamation walk
I'm definitely exclaiming
uh actually wait a second actually yeah
actually not a not the worst move ever
[Music]
this is how you keep it spicy with moves
like that yeah this
one was like every wish Danny you ever
like think about it and just be like I
wish I was like better at chess yeah
yeah I'm having them
every day
every single day
is what I want out of that world anymore
it's a beautiful day I agree for what
it's worth honey yeah
foreign
[Music]
wait a minute yep hold the phone phone a
friend what a friend photo friend wait
someone's got a little bit of spicy
ideas inside of him yeah yeah I think
you've planted we're talking about me no
the daddy yeah
all right looking lockheads let's do a
game seven I think I just pushed us to a
game seven baby oh man wow that was yeah
the content rolls on why
I've got nothing
absolutely nothing you're gonna give it
to me I got
I gotta have no moves wait a second oh
never mind
I felt like you probably had some better
oh I only have four seconds yeah
this is really it now game seven all
right Gambit I gotta go for the opening
that actually worked really well I'm not
gonna do okay I'm not gonna do that
again yeah the B5 before we're gonna do
oh my Geezer oh my geezer luizers
when you play against Legends courses
this is exactly what happens when you
play I'm gonna take it back okay
it was a mouse Loop it was a mouse slip
yeah
I haven't looked at it I'm probably just
walking into a trap
[Music]
you might walk into something that I
will use to promote my content
and this is why you should play
okay what is going on here I'm about to
just like absolutely get destroyed in
this game seven here we go we run
we run to the other side you run but you
cannot hide no this is already over I'm
completely lost yeah you can't hide
actually wait a second
it's all a trap it's not it's just like
to lose yeah it probably won like 100
games like this really it's not over yet
well I mean it's not over you can still
you can still play I'm gonna try but
this is fascinating
it's not over yet
try uh protect the meat well I can't
take on C8 if you play Queen yes exactly
oh yeah yeah okay but there's a catch he
doesn't have to take off here yeah
I'm not gonna go here anyway
hey but now it's not over at all but I'm
just I'm just completely schmucked no
it's still still getting busted and I
still have to win I've lost words I've
lost better positions
well I learned something today yeah this
line is that if I watch more Gotham
chess videos I'd be better at chess I
think this might be the D4 Dynamite I'm
not sure if I have a video but I'm you
know either is good either either is
good
[Music]
okay would you rather play Blitz only
for your whole life or would you rather
only play D-Day rated tournaments for
the rest of your life just as hard
enough and these these riddles are yeah
actually
it was just a problem
this whole game was a problem yeah my
life is a problem
Levy plays Tony let me plays Tony I get
out of here I don't feel good for myself
actually
that was amazing all right Johnny take a
seat